okay who do you think everybody I'm just
gonna go through the emergency
evacuation now link because I don't know
how many people here it's not a familiar
with the evacuation notice so should we
be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building fire
fire the nearest available exit that's
just behind counselor mrs. Mason there
is one for X in this room if you need to
evacuate the room do so by the glass
door to the external fire escape
staircase please hold both home raised
rails in place place the stairs are wet
or slippery if anyone is unable to use
the stairs they please allow others to
exit the room before they go to the fire
escape door where they can be given
assistance our assembly point will be
held at the public car pop and at the
sizes of explain please do not delay
effectuate their company belongings
please do not return to the built-in
until giving permission to do you set by
the council staff please note this
meeting will be audio recorded can I
please remind you to switch off your
mobile phones or turn them to silent
thank you
so is it pretty the agenda for silent
yes yeah great so apologies first of all
and policies received in the office from
counselor mrs. Leslie butcher the
substitute is counselor mrs. Danielle
Belton
I'm also counselor mrs. J good in the
substitute is counselor mr. Daniel FD
counselor Chris Stanley substitute
counselor James Newport and also present
out sorry also apologies from mrs.
Walker our independent person and
counselor from he sees Mandi Cohen it's
anybody got any other oh jeez it thank
you
non-members attending we have Angeline
yes that's me anybody else Oh counselor
mr. and mrs. Royce Oh Lorraine thank you
okay and minutes of the meeting held on
the first of October 2019 for those who
were present
I'd like to objective minutes madam
chairman if I may I'm objecting to the
minute 176 one-seventh ich as you will
recall this is a very short meeting yes
under four minutes so according to
meanings Inc I think that the answer was
for discussion according to the agenda
however the Chairman to told that the
item was for noting and then the meeting
was closed general in the interests of
accuracy I would request the minute be
altered to read that the Chairman
declared that the item was from noting
and that is because the committee did
not actually talk about whether to note
or discussed here until I have the
recording available to hear now if
there's any doubt as to efficacy of it
one question that will be altered
counselor mrs. Mason however could I
just say that I was at the meeting I
chaired the meeting I did put the item
for noting and there wasn't opportunity
to keep them for somebody to raise
anything because I did say is there any
questions nothing as make sure no afraid
your recollection I think he's wrong I
have the recording man listen to twice
she says for noting it's for noting
believe how's the writing there was that
there was an opportunity I'm not
criticizing you I just want the meeting
to be accurate thank you very much
councillor mace I do know that after the
meeting was closed you raised that very
question
perhaps if I should have mentioned it
was for noting in you felt it should be
for discussion could be in future
eating's perhaps and bring that forward
before I close the meeting I would have
done so had we been in opportunity three
that answer has always been for
discussion as the whole point of us
having it only because this committee
wanted to track it needed to see if
there's anything that could be done to
improve the standards and to prevent
complaints so it's always been for
debate
thank you and so in future we're going
to make sure that that's included and
for discussion as opposed to being
mounted
thank you very much counseling this is
for making more than two Thank You Alan
sorry chair thing not more like excuse
me I'm I'm sure I just go back sorry
Angela counselor Angelina Mary is a
independent person thank you very much
thank you
Hey moving on and so to receive
decorations have been tres SME for
decoration is interested oh thank you
then we're on to item number six and if
I can ask the officer to go through this
item claim I think chairman thank you
this report before the stands committee
to weakness to dimension of this
standards committee working groups
potentially just one thing are you
polling I'm just that was quite quiet
notice it's already didn't have a slice
it was like okay
could everybody hear okay I said yes
that's fine thing here so thank you
chairman the purpose of this report is
to reconstitute the membership with the
standards committee working group the
working group was constituted by this
committee on the 20th of June of this
year
unfortunately brought to my attention
that the membership is not strictly
correct in accordance with the
composition set down by counsel the
working group the council minutes of the
12th of December 2017 set that the
working group should comprise of the
chairman of this standards committee one
independent person and three members
cross party unfortunately in June it was
constituted with the vice chairman of
the Standards Committee and for members
for the working group and we have n
depend person I was properly constituted
we're here just to reconstitute that
membership Thank You chairman thank you
answer any questions thank you so no I'm
not many about wait for other people to
come here I was going to take you
through the history of the have what led
up to the council may see on the 12th of
December
they've started off in the Standards
Committee on the 16th of November and
I'll point you to the note on page 2
where it was stated on finding so I read
in him
whereas
it was hoped that the membership of the
working group should be across the
council's political groups as follows
Council MCC a Western as chairman of the
Standards Committee cast as Miss ECM
Mason counselors dfd and the agreed
independent person counselor cm Stanley
would be approached to ascertain whether
he'll be the fourth committee member of
the working group I it's quite clear the
intention and the standards committee at
that point that equals be across all
political groups that and I can't
remember why I was called in to review
committee on the fifth of December and
the the review committee stated and I
mean their own bill the review committee
what as things move around I mean
treasury management stated it brought up
through the import and it agreed with
the standards committee and said that
the working group bean
I pointed on the same basis as that
standards committee it says in the
report item 8% of the members Learning
and Development the report where today
the article wordings there that it was
agreed which we tell you this is the now
the review committee report eight item
eight of the fifth of December 2017
rifle and that repeated the same the
same item is that not just finished
playing because our think is quite
important that people understand the
nature of it with the obviously what the
intention is so that the status quickly
intended for it to be cross group all
groups to be participating in the
working group the review committee
agreed that and recommended that to full
council and for council held on the
twelfth for council then voted on it and
used slightly different wording book
clearly the chairman of the committee
plus three cross party members i three
three three the three members as already
identified I believe as named in the
standards treaty and in there and not
that name sake the review which we both
agree by the review committee so I think
the intention is quite clear that the
the the group should be membership of
all political groups on the council now
is the intention from the stands
committee through from the six days of
November to the review committee on the
5th of December and then fall Council on
the 12 December intention and what was
voted on full council was voted on on
the basis of the review committee recall
yeah
and what was what was the actual wording
because it was voted at forecastle
chairman if I may assist so council
voice is correct in paragraph one point
five of the review committee report the
fifth of December it states that the
committee felt would be appropriate for
the working group to be drawn from
members of the standards committee with
each political group representative and
that it would be useful to have an
independent
person's input in advisory capacity
so that is the intention of the review
and the Standards Committee the
recommendation however of that review
committee didn't reflect that and the
same recommendation was put forward to
full council the recommendation was that
their working group of the standards
committee comprising of the chairman of
the committee three other cross group
members an independent person so it
didn't actually well it didn't refer
that it should be from each political
party I'm sorry okay so constitutionally
is what we voted on as the wording on
the four council the college council
wording was that it is exactly the same
as the wording of the review committee
that's a working group of the standards
committee comprising of the chairman of
the committee three other cross group
members and independent person in
advisory that we discussed earlier
counselor mrs. basement thank you madam
chair I don't believe you were on this
committee at the time this was discussed
that's correct but there was a very
lengthy and I'm sure they members that
were on there while getting some
acknowledgement there it was a very
lengthy and detailed discussion on this
and the feeling was that member training
was so important and the the intention
was to encompass as much should we say
agreement across part a in a cross
growth and as much input from all of the
groups as possible so that it was fit
for purpose for all the groups rather
than favoring one and that was the
intention I think very roughly between
that and also it's a democratic decision
as well I think we've got two issues
here I mean with hindsight it's clear
that the working group should not have
been agreed as it is now in the meeting
of the 20th of June but
science a wonderful thing mistakes been
made aware he was rectified that's not
the issue in fact it's probably so
positive but it should have been as
originally discussed and then accepted I
think by this committee and by the
review committee and by implication if
not unfortunately the wording of the
minute that went through was not as
clear as it might have been but one
member from each of the political groups
with the Chairman included representing
a group but if something else is now
solved something different then we will
have to go back to full council but
regardless of the decision of this
committee tonight under the constitution
of the working group pursuing that they
constitute it within the regulations
that we have in there I think it might
be sensible to go back to full council
and to ask them to give the Standards
Committee the power to constitute its
own working group in the future to avoid
future problems I've not come across a
situation before when one committee has
effectively tied the hands of another
committee and that's what has happened
here this went forward from the review
committee why I don't know but it
doesn't really matter I don't think the
intention was for indefinitely it says
for future years I don't think that was
in the original draft and I'm crowdcast
I thought I can probably correct me I do
eyes on that I don't think that was the
intention I think it was just for
intended for that one year but what we
have done by default at full council is
tied the hands of a committee of full
council and I don't think that was
intended so one of the things I think
that we should be discussing tonight
it's the way forward so this situation
doesn't occur again to put the power
back to the committee does that make
sense
we were looking for a few smashing thank
you as you write this out what's not
here what other members who were here
like - I just come in this Ari Sherman
my understanding is I could be wrong
that the status committee said I paid
working group to do the training and my
understanding from there is every year
be a chairman and three other as you
said one committee and that's it yeah
that's my me from this I don't
understand why you why do you why are we
saying we need to are you so I use that
we need to change that yeah I'm not
saying we need we need to change it
particularly what what I'm saying is
that unfortunately this minute from the
12th of December ties the hands of this
committee to that I've got no problem
with that arrangement if the committee
wants it to be tied to that they're not
perfectly happy with it cuz I was part
of the original committee that make that
arrangement I've got no problem with it
being the chairman and a member the
three groups as we have no but it's tied
to the full council which makes it say
for example next year we have four
groups or five great awesome fire grids
you've got four down so say we have five
groups then this minute is difficult and
also full council is has directed us and
I don't think it's directed but don't
think there's any intent but the problem
is that we have got to do exactly what
that minion for counsel says whereas it
would be quite sensible to go back to
full counsel and saying that in future
the Stannis committee can determine the
membership of the working group I mean
that's an alternative I don't have an
issue with it one way or the other but I
think it's something that should be
considered
can I just thank you the chip the
question and how soon can we return now
after decisions be made six months so it
returned as the to council and to change
that decision well yeah okay the
decision of the council we've got stood
the composition was meeting in 2017 so
how I give if the composition as council
mrs. Mason says was to be changed even
EP to be taken back to the next annual
council meeting I just wonder why it's
taken so long to actually question that
um the sorry no no okay the working
group that was constituted earlier this
year has been brought to my attention it
wasn't constituted in line with the the
minute of the 2017 it just seems that it
is an issue for one individual if not
more and I'm just wondering when I when
that review committee mini appeared and
then subsequently went to Council and
became the resolution but it wasn't
questioned then through the chair I
think at the time when this went to full
council it had been so long as nuts in
both committees both review and
standards there was a consensus and
everyone had an understanding in their
mind
unfortunately the written word doesn't
exactly reflect and it roughly public's
it doesn't exactly reflect what the
intention was but we are where we are
but this turned out but if I could just
HM and say
if it was that important really in my
view it that should have been checked at
the time as to what was scratching
yourself by council I think it's very
much thing to have hindsight well girls
I think as councillor room which is nice
and say something good
the intention is quite here in the
report through did everybody on the
Standards Committee had understood the
report everybody reviewed but he'd
understood three poll and I think there
was a there was a more of them you're
passing in relation to what you
understood the report to say rather than
naturally the exact wording nothing in
retrospect we will find ourselves
looking back two years later at some
recourse I think if you don't that's not
quite how I remember it
and I think in some ways the wordings
don't always reflect the intention do
they nothing that's the problem is I
think come to right now that the wording
doesn't actually relay the intention
nothing the wording also gives
difficulty if there was a change of the
number of groups as well which hadn't
read being realized at the time he's not
real and my only point would be
obviously wasn't around then in terms of
the council and the written word surely
is the better memory than the memory and
given that you would review the minutes
and argue the minutes and find it
surprising if it wasn't great if it
wasn't correcting what was discussed you
wouldn't have picked that out in the
written minutes at the time there's
nothing wrong in the written minutes
yeah if you really mean line with the
with the with the agendas and the
reports if you read within our report
you understand that the the the wording
of the decision
relates to the wording within the
meeting and that's understandable
but when you've read it without it and
that's quite common that's what for us
is quite commonly part of our reports
when you actually read that the
decisions drive you can have a different
understanding of what was meant
I'm going back and sinking down I'm not
too sure but I thought the I get the
feeling you had our committee head out
when we had been our Spanish Committee
we were looking at the how many
counselors were on that Stennis
committee even if we have seven or eight
different groups if those people are not
on the Standards Committee we can't
reduce these and we cannot have them on
the working group and I think at the
time we looked at that issue and there
was only three or four of us who work on
that Stennis give up could be wrong and
what I also really also think we also
decided with if it's more than one then
we would obviously offer that was my
understanding it Angelo could you
confirm that from the makeup off so I'm
just tryna could you see if the
membership of the committee don't need
three working parties they say we chose
four three whatever if it was four and I
think at that time we didn't have I
didn't think I didn't believe with all
the members of the whole council full
onset a different working partners often
on the committee that so chairman yes
members working groups are not formal
committees as such it doesn't need to be
pro rata it doesn't need to be pro rata
and and non members of a of a committee
can if they have show interest can can
be nominated to join that working group
if they wants to but I mean that will be
through agreement with members of that
committee doesn't need to be
madam chairman if I can perhaps add some
clarity to that I think in some ways
councillor West is right well at that
point in time we did have
representatives of all four groups on
the Standards Committee so it was
logical from that perspective but what
we never envisaged was there would be
less or more groups on it wouldn't do it
naturally not your visit we were looking
at the situation that was in front of us
at the time and I don't know if the
future years was on the original report
perhaps counselor who can tell us off
that's something that's got added in so
I don't believe it was the intention to
tie down the committee indefinitely but
it doesn't really matter because it that
is that is the meaning that we're
working to the meaning of the 12th of
December so as I see it this committee
has got two decisions to make
one is to formulate a working group in
line with the decision past my full
council on the 12th of December to is to
consider whether or not this committee
wants to ask for counsel and it would be
quite easy to do so the recommendation I
don't believe it has to go through to
annual council I think it go to full
council because we were outside the
sixth month for all so - if you want to
to give the power to the committee to
set its own working group rather than be
tied by what was determined on the 12th
of December 2017 alternatively if the
committee is happy to be tied to that
decision then obviously the second part
of that is unnecessary does that make
sense the chorus I don't believe it does
tie future years when you read the
actual decision because the future use
is referring to the training program up
there constitutionally working group yes
very I don't think he's just a not very
good wording but I think
both ways I think the way the
penetration works I think it's quite
clear let's bring in our independent
member think it's amazing our peoples
members when we set up Standards
Committee many years ago it was
independent of the council it was
independent of the council of rules it
was to make sure that the council did
things for its public and not for itself
that's the first thing that seems to be
missing from this conversation secondly
having then sat and watched Eve's party
changes members on a rotary basis
subject was on the committee obviously
we're not going to end up with the same
amount of groups we could end up with
one group you never know so when we come
to a working group the main idea came
that this was to do training of
councillors and I will lovely sign most
of them want training I have an opinion
that they know it don't need to be tried
and we've come very near on many
occasions to come in on stuck as a
council so we set up a working group for
everybody to put their input into it now
next year we might only have two parties
if you want
then we would be stuck because those
parties would have to choose amongst
them the ones on the working group you
can't bring people all over the place to
start making the roads it should be
members of the standards committee but
are not a 94u groups we've one
independent opportunity excuse me energy
could you listen
sonic you mention thank you if on the
basis that we've got a working as an
independent person watching you all I
would like to see a view from each of
those groups and I would worry about it
if we only add one group and it was only
their view and for the for council to
tell us how to run the standards of them
I think that's insulting and as a member
of the public I'm not very happy with me
it's correct simple we can have a
chairman it can be the chairman of the
standards committee sit on this group
each party each one of you can nominate
a member and then there's only free
independent people and we've agreed how
we're going to sit there sometimes it's
boring sometimes is funny only want to
do the funny ones
and then we go forward so we're making a
big deal about some idiot writing words
down
it wasn't even at this meeting and all
we want is a chairperson of this because
that's what we need that person doesn't
have to be the chairperson of the
working group
it could be just those people vote today
on so when's the next finger they come
from from full council to tell us who's
gonna chair the working group is getting
ridiculous
we need an individual from each one of
your groups and the independent members
to sit there and feel comfortable with
what you are doing the rest of it so
what's the problem
why don't we just put it up now each
group Norman is a person you can even
have a parish remember if you want one
but they're a little bit on the edge of
it but you could have a parish man the
ceiling is working for it because they
have to be trained as well no I'm not
well I'm just saying that could happen
yep and it might be a benefit to the
council because most of the complaints
come through from parishes because
they're not all trained so I really find
it hard to sit here and listen to people
who are not even sitting here the mic in
the open although I would like you to do
is nominate a person from each of your
groups the chairperson of this meeting
and then we're going to a work
group we're so well who they are to
share it and it should really not even
have any politics in it it should be
basically trying to train members to do
their job without it reflecting on the
council I don't know I like that that
one is we have two legal requirements
the people who sit on licensing and
appeals have to know the law and really
should be up to date yearly and I have
been told by some of our staff that
sometimes they struggle to get that
council or that group of people together
because we haven't or maybe not have
enough people at some point and if that
happens we're end up being caught
because we could be excluding someone
from their living no no actually not a
working group understand why noise I
just want the stages of this council to
be good understand that what we're here
tonight for the reason why I think we're
here is because when we sets up a second
that this business group again we set
out with different people one of the
person wasn't the chairman it ended up
being out I think it was Robin or two
conservatives in who's really it wasn't
the correct the correct amounts of be by
the chairman and three or four other
people in the colony different points in
it the whole of the council elected
councillor Mason was saying yes when the
when of those four or five people get
together when they have their meeting
like we did we sat there and we decided
with a chairman was nothing to do with
the standards at all so they have we
have our five people they sit there
mr. chairman we decided to be Christine
and it was fine and it worked fine
we're not here to say everybody's name
we start from scratch let's read
nominate the people to sit on was
working as a ball were messing about we
can't do that we have to now follow the
Constitution what but that can be
changed in the future and perhaps that's
a task that the working group wouldn't
care well then let's do that get over
all the squabbling
let's go back to working group then in
send back so let's come back to the
agenda the recommendation here under 5.1
is proposed that committee resolves to
reconstitute the membership of the
member training working group so there
is properly constituted the remainder of
the 2019-20 municipal year in nine
reports were what was determined at the
council on the 12th of December 2017
would you like to answer just remind
everybody the membership of that so
chairman the membership would be
yourself
yeah one independent and three other
members right so um counselor mr. Spacek
will you join the working group agamya
council mrs. Mason spend and the
chairing and has a lot of his tube is
there the group who else here was
present I know you both ndj I was yeah
yes it would have to be remembered the
liberal group and a member of the Green
Party sausages as we've got represents
both here we can ask them for their
nominations you're both still members of
this group don't have two members of the
class it doesn't say you have to be a
member of the committee
well I suppose based at least I mean
it had to be members of the Standards
Committee even on TV
we out them plays with the plates we
have a legal adviser here it's a German
to be clear working groups doesn't need
to consist of members of the actual
committee yeah they're informal with
regards to the cross group members the
report back in 2017 did have the
intention that those members should be
from each political group however a
minute itself didn't reflect that so it
would be a matter for this committee to
make that decision as to who the
membership is as long as there are two
minimum political groups to make that
cross policy
so there is the tip the attention was
set but that was reflected formally in a
minute right so constitutionally we have
to follow that minuting from the
December 4 count so in 2017 is that
correct under the minute says three
other cross movement ISM three other
cross group members so that's yourself
mr. counselor Stanley
this helps us Daniel I believe family
and counselors died in Hawaii you I
wasn't hearing German but you nothing
you're willing to continue yeah have we
have been importantly just to clarify
because this sounds up which say it has
to be one from each party whereas my
understates are great where is my
understanding from what Angela just read
there is cross party doesn't mean each
group across group doesn't mean each
group it just means more than one group
yes so that's how it's been minute is
however the intention in the report was
there shall be fun
but we the matter for this committee to
decide that membership we follow through
is there anybody else who wants to be a
member and then what we go for a vote
I want this correct well I'm happy to
stay there previously
if I'm able to so chairman if you had
you would need to take a vote on those
nominations for which I've been chairman
hard I'm afraid that if the group is
Constitution other than one from each
group member
I would not be willing to serve and nor
would any one of my group the intention
regardless of the minute which we
obviously have to honor we have all
agreed that the intention was for one
member at that time it was one in review
kick one member of the green and hostage
District residents group one member of
the Conservative Party and welcome
member with the liberal party so it was
always intended to be one member
representing each specific result now if
this committee because of a minute that
perhaps I won't so the minute is wrong
but it's not as clear as it should have
been and it's only now or when in June I
suppose it which should have been picked
up when the committee was very done but
it's only now that we've hindsight we're
all reauthorizing the problems that that
has created I feel that we should honor
the intention which also honors the
wording of the minutes of the 12
December it it resolves the problem
because we've a dependent person has
brought up in their own all
we'll be represented and I think we
should continue as was intended if the
intention of this committee is to alter
that and say that just one person on
there cause across party then I'm afraid
I'm not prepared to endorse any
circumstances who could put I asked for
anything because standards and I'm happy
to share this because I see it has
non-political we are here to review
standards of all parties right
the working group again I would hope
would be made up of people who would
like to represent their party on there
and have their voice heard and input
into the training sessions so are you
saying if this went for a vote and some
people didn't win that vote you would
not want to be representing your group
on this we're not saying that I'm saying
that the intention of the both as has
been clearly demonstrated was for a
member of each political group political
party whatever you want to call it to be
representative so that we got the best
possible training that suited the most
people so that it it was truly
representative of the whole council it
was nothing to do with politics it was
to do with getting the most input and
because you've got different people from
different groups they were able to amaze
and feedback from their groups with much
better clarity and with much greater
honesty than if it comes from a
different group and the intention was to
make it non-political as far as possible
and to make them the training as member
orientated as possible and I think it's
achieved that I think it's done very
well but if it's going to become
politically biased by having a different
makeup than was originally intended
because of a minute that is less
than perhaps we anticipated then I
wouldn't want to be party to that now
you see I'm in a situation here where I
have to make sure it's constitutionally
correct so I can't go on history or what
was intended I have to go on the written
word for that fault you didn't on the
20th of June which is why we're
discussing this now so the situation is
madam chairman that we can do exactly
what was intended and at the same time
go with the written word just in
fairness there I was not made aware of
how makeup of the group had to be able
to 29th of June okay so I'm just saying
that mistakes happen and Palestine
happens and they don't happen and it
we're here to correct that what I am
saying is anyone who is on to working
group or go with the intentions of
supporting accounts not with their
political banner and you're saying to me
that if we went for a vote here and you
can go through a bogey if it's your
tutelage in your agenda maybe it may not
be um I I personally would like to see
you on that and I I feel that you would
be a good representation for your group
and with the experience that you've
fought but you're really saying to me if
I ask people to vote and somebody loses
I will go I feel a little bit now what
might surface didn't do and I don't
think I'm a focusing for me or against
me I've got no problem with that talk
but no problem with me having a fact
what I have a problem with is that when
we can carry out as a committee both the
intention of the committee the intention
of review committee which has been well
spoken about now and comply with the
written word I don't see why you
wouldn't want to do that it's as simple
as that the written one that says one
thing the intention says another but
they can be married up and we can comply
their own
okay and so a counselor okay um I was
actually on this at that time and I do
remember it being it was gonna be for
each political group to go back to their
don't back and say to what's happening
and if as I read it on here yeah she
says the chairman at the time was in the
Conservatives gained as amended
conservatives pains free other people
from at a time he was his windings free
groups she was in history groups now and
an independent so if we want to move
away from that we need to vote if we're
going to move away from that get some
new songs which need to be a super fun I
can see why we can't do that until he
comes around in a skit reconstituted in
my becomes did you know when it comes
back to four counts it it's a if you
want to change the composition you'd
have to go to full council is that the
first station two full cameras at the
one in the Dyson already council me to
it be next full council next what else
SME you still need to finish so that's
how you also need to decide but maybe a
bit no I'm not a meeting how you want
working to be Constitution of accounts
meeting to sort this out yeah
so for me I think I think it's clear
nothing if you really the intention was
for as it was then for political groups
and as it is now for political groups
ought to be represented on the working
party
the wording doesn't quite working on
that but they're both compatible you can
still have that you can have four
members of the all for political groups
on the working party and it agrees with
the written word in the Constitution I
think perhaps that the first option see
the wording in that in from the forecast
of the 12th of December should be maybe
reword it in a better way and perhaps
not bind the committee even he seems to
be ridiculousness has been saved on life
serve on the review
a number of years and never ever been
told but [ __ ] out of water but working
party should consist of some quite
surprised that was that ever happened
but I think they're not incompatible the
to two items the intention and the
wording can both be a can what both work
together file for groups being
represented yes thank you don't even
come back I think in order to resolve
this matter chairman perhaps if I can
put a recommendation to this committee
and then we can see if there's a
consensus and if there's not then we
further discussion I would recommend
that the working group for the member
training program for the community of
the year nineteen twenty to twenty one
is constituted of the with the chairman
of this committee
we've councillor Chris Stanley with
myself and we can sir dine hi have I got
a seconder for that recommendation okay
would actually be for the current
municipal you know get the current yeah
oh yeah it's not a training at American
TV show yes
nineteen twenty members are agreed to
that membership in you can agree that
now that would be in line with the
council minute of 2017 right show of
hands please
so that's her political party it's so
charming to be clear for the remainder
of this municipal year the working group
will consist of yourself one independent
person that would need to be again
nominated for an amish that yes
counselor mrs. Mason cancer certainly
and counselor mrs. hoy so we need to
nominate an independent person to afford
well how can we have five people vote
for that
you know there's many people on the
committee it is only eight dancers five
little Georgie fine thank you
so we now we need to nominate nominate
Shepherd right yes madam chairman yes
ma'am
make a recommendation to prevent this
becoming difficult in the future because
I know council long we would like to
serve I would have liked to work with it
I think it would have it's a pity the
way it's been worded that we are
actually tired I won't and it's not
crystal we like to work with you it's
just I think it's a shame the way it's
been restricted and I don't think that
was the intention either so I've judged
something down here that may or may not
resolve this don't you step in now I
would prefer to see it as another agenda
might on our next meeting to discuss if
we do that madam chairman it will take
the next meeting is until January title
for council and the problem is one of
the issues that we found resolved is
that we couldn't get the detail through
enough to get the trainer's because we
were too late and we've had difficulty
obtaining trainers because and we're
probably going to be in that situation
again now because of this slight delay
because trainers get booked up a year or
two in advance or some cases I mean we
show you've had problems with that
haven't you'd lost time so what I would
like to do and I would like to make a
recommendation because this is under the
same subject that in future years the
standard committee determines the
members of the working group for the
member training for
choosing one representative from each
political group one independent member
and and running dependent member
politically I mean if we have any
independent members and one independent
member from here in an advisory capacity
just so that the determination of the
committee structure the working group
structure comes back to this committee
relevant arrays with the for Council
which I think we've all been slightly
surprised it shouldn't remain before
council that's fundamental and I think
mr. shadow was quite right we shouldn't
be to being told by four counts or how
to constitute working group so I think
we were to take that back charity mummy
just might be a better word and so did
you repeat the wording that Cassie is
that in future years the Standards
Committee determined the members of the
working group for the member training
program choosing one representative from
each critical group and one independent
member and and an independent member as
an advisory I've added on an independent
member because we at the moment have
three independent counselors I don't see
any reason why they couldn't be included
but if you don't want that I have no
that's welcome could aren't you think
how does that fit in with other working
groups because I sit on review as do
quite a few people in here and often the
people who stepped forward to be on
those working parties are all from one
party so you're therefore getting the
people who want to be on that working
group who want to input into that
subject I think we've already discussed
that at length the reason for having one
from each political group is to get the
feedback and get consensus this is if
this is trying to make it non-political
when other other committees set up their
working groups it's up to them how they
determine it it's not a police committee
to determine what other groups do
so I think chairman in a roundabout way
will almost ended up in the same kind of
wording to food Council put your asking
Council to make a better tutor to to
come in a decision where you're asking
the stands committee to set up working
group from each political party okay
better as you say to say can the full
counts quick draw meditation to full
council that the composition of the
working group be decided and constituted
by this Standards Committee yes last
year two chicken because I I do so I
have a problem that we may then be
cobbling ourselves again to having to
pick those people and I know from
experience because I'm on the carbon
neutral I'm on the refuse working group
from review some people will not
actively put themselves forward for
these working groups or even austerity
people most people didn't put themselves
forward but that's the review committee
working group ceases to be outstanding
we've not had an issue here halfway of
anymore putting themselves scourge in
factory we've got the opposite situation
if you look at it we put more people
that want to serve them and we we need
to go back to the council and get that
that minute of the 12th of December
reversed and perhaps the legal officer
can advise us the best way of doing that
because I don't think he's right if that
these committees committee like this
going nothing yessir I don't think that
Mitty should be determined
it's a standards committee should be an
independent committee is a committee of
all counts
and yet by some round-robin way it's had
its hands tied by a report from review
committee and I'm sure that was never
the intention
Chairman I would say that if if they if
you want to make that recommendation and
if the working group is to be decided by
this committee and the conversation is
to be decided by this committee then
this can if if members of each political
group wants to come forward and serve on
that working group then that wouldn't
actually happen it doesn't tie you down
to say three members four members five
members at present
you know it will be down to this
committee to decide the composition of
that okay um give a part of the working
you should make it sound so complicated
I was going back to work I go back to my
intention where I thought it was
standards committee we did it set up a
working group to talk about the training
and I had the impression I have thought
and they will be complete as an
involvement for the ends of it you know
on the standards committee for the
people to go on that working group and I
remember one of the members with Chris
daily because he wasn't that meeting we
said he would might want to join the
review party I don't think they would
because I my concern is you could end up
having team different groups are you
then going to say you were out Tempe
were on only that wasn't the intention
any intention of the Working Party have
a small working and it's cancer Mason
pointed out very very clearly that we
needed to make sure the training was
done correctly the way we needed it
because we were doing it all over the
place we won't get into the crux of it
and if you end up having half a dozen
six seven eight members we're never
gonna get it we that's why we decided I
believe working party it was going to be
small and just people from understanding
that's committee I could well be wrong I
think those groups should be small I
mean the definition of it is a working
group and the detailer you go into you
need it to be sorted but you're quite
right council mystery
never achieved that with a larger group
can I just say that I think the just
going over stuff we've talked about I
thought what Angela law said it was
perfectly fine I need it brings back
control let's cancel missus West's sit
back into the control of the standards
we take about doing that and then you
can be flexible if there are if there
are ten different groups then perhaps it
wouldn't be appropriate but at the
moment there are four groups and it
seems hardly appropriate and it gives us
a feeling about this because if it comes
down to next year us deciding amongst
ourselves who is on that working group
what happens if the vote doesn't go
somebody's way although they're not
going to want to be on the group we
can't tell the future no but in all
fairness counselor mrs. Mason you said
that if this went to a vote you would
step away from me I think I said no to a
vote it was it was be equated to about
it it has been voted on what I said was
I would be uncomfortable we were being
unbalanced and I would withdraw if it
was unbalanced because the whole
intention of this was that it was the
political mistake announcement and it
was balanced between the groups so that
we had a higher level of communication
and it and it has achieved that we have
had a very good level of communication
between members we're getting
information back that probably we
wouldn't have had otherwise balanced is
a good work thank you and ultimately
whatever the working group decides comes
back to this committee a nice okay
everybody half of them just said um I
think is is equally important is that
membership of working groups have some
enthusiasm for being where they are
told because we have a place you must be
there because I don't want to and all
we've done so far is delayed the process
of sorting out the member training as
you said earlier to get people booked
what we've determined started to
determine would be the program for next
year and that's disappointing that we're
I think he's doing because two members
couldn't make it wasn't it it was
conservative members couldn't make it so
and then they really just say I also did
I was out another representing lots of
district councillor another yeah I know
yeah but then the leader of the council
actually canceled the meeting so we
weren't allowed to go ahead with it but
but bearing in mind that presumably by
there was someone who'd get picked up
that it was unconstitutional was the
reason is understandable though that
wasn't conveyed at the time I didn't Amy
okay so we will look at the membership
ourselves we can put that on please for
the next agenda item for a few years
doesn't I need to go to full council it
needs to go back to protesters and
there's no reason madam chair well we
can't do it tonight I don't understand
the denied okay it's everybody
comfortable with that or would you like
to pieces now with we have no
constitutes a group to the rest of the
yes yeah which is in Mike so if we go so
get some next council meeting which
won't be this won't be the one in
January that we won't change it if
that's gonna cause a problems we've know
it will be from the next municipal year
won't it'll be from me
all right so okay so comes back before
council then we're gonna change it but
from my not from that council I don't
know why I don't care cuz yep no no it'd
be from the next municipal year yeah
that's what I see
but actually there once you're done
enter because I'm not sure when the next
meeting of this committee is but I think
it's quite late in the year and then we
would be tying ourselves up and not
getting things thrown it seems silly
when we were all sitting in here we've
discussed this I'm about an hour now
there seems to be a general consensus
why don't we put it forward as a
recommendation and since it's so
charming before I give you the wording
so practically this recommendation will
go to full council let's just say it's
agreed then
starting from the new missile year I
suggest that a report comes to this
committee yes reflecting all the
discussions we had today to speak so all
members are clear that when you're
constituting the new working group it
will be drawn from members of all
political rooms and an independent
personal to necessary it could be they
don't necessarily have to have the
chance it a little bit down to this but
I think the main crops of a lady should
be drawn that your your that members of
this wants it to be drawn from all
political boobs so that'll be a report
to come forward to this committee then
those nominations can come forward
working group our teams have a small
people to discuss the training it's not
anymore I'm just I'm just concerned they
depend on you more than more you're
gonna like it
he's gonna he's gonna if I make I think
engineer was just terrifying the
positioning that such that it brings
brought back into control the stance
committee and I answered the report to
be just a memorandum report so beyond so
the new members cuz it could be
completely new membership next time
understood the history of
the working group worked and what what
it was so if they worked great I think
ten members of a working group before
unmanageable today but it might be
appropriate sir it's up to the committee
surety to be sorry sorry reflecting on
the wording of the review committee in
December 2017 the wording was the
committee phobia practically working
group to be drawn from members of the
Standards Committee with each political
group that is the wording and that was
the intention that sat down and the
report can be it's been agreed that the
composition is to be is to sit with this
that a report can be brought forward to
this group standards to to reflect that
same intention and to make it clear when
nominating forward those members of the
working group there the original
attention was may I suggest an amendment
that some some days the understanding
I'm getting is that you've got to keep
small is beautiful we're working groups
are concerned and from my personal
experience of equity so and arguing that
you this idea where you want to try and
get a diverse representation so if you
have an amendment that states drilled
from say four groups or maximum of four
groups or the four largest groups or
however you want to do it there's
something that makes sure that was
there's plenty of representation but you
put care on so each group provides in
that growth exceeds no more than X so
you you you you as members obviously
choose what your X's but you needed a
so it doesn't creep up to take my call
so the X could be four or five whatever
you decide but you need a cap that solve
this this debate you're having about Oh
what if as eight groups well that's not
workable so you need to careful of site
three four five whatever you decide to
set it to do just correct maybe the
stance is committing is paragraph two
representation of the groups yes so
therefore just nominations from those
who are represented understand
discussing there's a I thought it was
quite nothing you're just trying to saw
your hands again why don't you just say
he's going to be brought back from my
it's going to be brought back to the
standards committee to decide and you
just decide each year what is going to
be I can't see why you've got such big
problems with not tying something in a
few today only one over you it might be
someone else it might be you but surely
as Ike committee why do you want to tie
your type you to committees down to
something which might be unworkable next
year in the same way as happened in 2017
surely what the engine or said is
perfectly fine you can get lots of your
fat your fix at the letter of December
and just say in future the Standards
Committee chocolates
and so just try to take in all this the
only thing I would say there counselor
FOIA is you're sad about the count the
committee tine itself down but you also
you want to get cross party or cross
group and diversity representation but
you also want to limit the numbers you
can't necessarily do both situation
using the wording that's been said by
Angela because if you say every a member
of every group has to be representative
meaning of five years time has ten
groups you've then got ten people plus
an independent so I think it needs to be
more along the lines of a working group
no larger than five members that consist
of individuals from and select
groups and whatever the wedding would
think yeah I think right I'm gonna draw
this to a close I think what you're
saying is that it will be down to the
standards committee to decide on the
number and the makeup of the borough
thank you I knew 18 I'll even put a
recommendation for Casa which is what
would be saying good Dean okay yeah gone
in favor okay
right so it's very mention so this
committee is now and voted on the second
recommendation in addition to the this
committee is recommending a second
recommendation in addition to the report
recommending to full council that the
composition of the working group to be
decided and constituted by the standards
committee starting from the next
municipal year 1920 onwards nineteen
twenty or twenty twenty recommendations
to for council the composition of the
working group to be decided and
constituted by the standards committee
starting from the next municipal year
1920
do we need to were constituted in there
because does that then set against time
to talk where's that that's what you
have to copy you have to pay when are we
going to say to a maximum of five
members from as many different groups as
impossible because I want that's what
features what people are you talking
about which is because otherwise it I
think the thing should trust Rebekah me
to stuff yeah future committee should be
under I agree that I thought see we
should be tied down I think that it
should be a decision of this community
to put in green just a point on that
chairman the music municipal year
next year is 2022 2021 okay right I
think I can say that counsel white
clothes II don't know okay
okay I was probably done by having to
propose this it would that second tip
thank you
okay I'll be there it's anybody got any
other questions I just have one cause
for yes one question at the moment is
this stands committee is done for free
groups on it because the greens are not
90 so yes we're not trying to just pick
up the standard for me it said anybody
yes oops
just making sure thank you any other
questions cuz I went to captain ippity
sure if you're going to thank you then I
this meet his coat they